virginia's newly elected lieutenant
governor winsome sears utterly
destroying the left's narrative after
the media claimed racism is why
republicans won on tuesday
this is about the fact that a good chunk
of voters out there are okay with white
supremacy they're dangerous they're
dangerous to our national security
because stoking that kind of soft white
nationalism
eventually leads to the hardcore stuff
but sears who was the first female and
woman of color elected state to
statewide office in virginia is hitting
back
i'm destroying all the narratives about
race
look at me
look at me i am a heartbeat away from
the governorship in case anything
happens to the governor and and how are
you going to tell me then i'm a victim i
wish joy reed would invite me on her
show i'm let's see if she's woman enough
to do that i'd go in a heartbeat and we
have a real discussion without joy
speaking about me
behind my back if you will
she talks about white supremacy does she
know that i ran against a white
supremacist
i mean joy come on get your facts
straight and then come talk to me
jesse don't you love this woman i'd pay
to see her go on reid's show that we all
were good i don't know if joy has the i
don't know what you'd call it to booker
yes
but she needs the lieutenant government
governor to be a victim and she's not a
victim and that's why she's such a
threat to joy reading the democrats crt
is a stain on the legacy of martin
luther king remember he aspired to have
a colorblind society you don't judge
people by the color of their skin the
content of their character joy reed all
she wants to see is color
she just wants to strip everything else
out and all you see is color you don't
see grit you don't see education you
don't see free will and that's the point
they can't talk about it that's why it's
so stealth and you know what dana it was
like larry elder when he ran for
governor in the recall in california
okay he's an african-american but he's a
white supremacist she is uh i think
jamaican but she's a white supremacist
you know that that's just their term for
republicans isn't it yes apparently for
joy and the other thing that she said is
that this you they get elected and then
that's what leads to the really hard
stuff right as if electing a black
female to lieutenant governor of
virginia is a gateway drug to white
supremacy this is absurd and the thing
is there's a in mentoring circles that
there's a thing there's a saying you
need to see her to be her okay so this
is the idea that when you're a little
girl it's a good idea to
be exposed to a lot of different women
executives or
report whatever you want to do in your
life you should be able to oh i can do
that oh i could do that so you think
about all the young black girls who can
watch winsome sears and say wow that's
another thing that i could aspire to
that i could see myself doing
winsome sears and the lieutenant
governor i'm sorry the attorney general
who won they are replacing democrats who
actually were accused of sexual abuse
sexual assault and wearing black face
right if winsome sears and the new i'm
sorry for getting his name the new
attorney general were democrats right
now you know what they would be doing
they would be calling them to run in
2024 because the democrats two-thirds of
them say they don't want biden to run no
that's what it would have happened you
know geraldo aoc and the squad has been
totally silent about this this historic
win by winsome sears uh and they were
even asked about it and they refused to
comment
what does it tell you about them it
tells you about ideological blindfolds
because
they didn't see larry elder for he who
he was look at tim scott in south
carolina he came up with a police reform
bill that was much better than the one
the democrats offered and he brought
republican support implicit in his
drafting of the legislation but he's a
black man who's very accomplished and
the their feeling is and
you know i go back to you know their
historic roles that they play but their
feeling is if you're not democrat you're
not black and i think that that is
really really unfortunate and that's
that's tragic and you know they got to
get over it but it comes from the top
greg i mean that's what joe biden said
you know if you don't like me then
you're wearing black if you're an
african american
joy reid can't invite her on the show
she has to pretend she doesn't exist
because that has to that has to protect
their false narrative of white supremacy
if you if you actually see this person
your whole your whole thing falls apart
but what if they are right in one
respect that there are white voters
choosing white supremacy except there
are rich white liberals voting democrat
in arlington fairfax and loudoun county
they vote democrat and they vote for
policies like higher taxes right climate
change agendas progressive education
anti-police reform these are all things
that a white rich liberal can afford but
the black working class can't so
here lies the gravest error of the left
they when they go after the white
working class they're going after the
black working class and they they
pretend by choosing uh these these this
incredible amount of spending it's a
virtue signal for them they pretend
they're doing well but they're actually
hurting everybody because they've
shifted from class to race and they
can't get out of it so in my opinion
it's the rich white liberal who votes
democrat who is the real racist because
they are hurting the black working class
as they try to hurt the white working
class